[Music]
how pleasant it can be
alone in a first class railway carriage
on the first day of a holiday that is to
be fairly long
to dawdle through a bit of english
country that is unfamiliar
stopping at every station you have a map
open on your knee and you pick out the
villages that lie to right and left by
their church towers
you marvel at the complete stillness
that attends your stoppage at the
stations
broken only by a footstep crunching the
gravel
yet perhaps that is best experienced
after sundown
and the traveler i have in mind was
making his leisurely progress on a sunny
afternoon in the latter half of june
he was in the depths of the country i
need not particularize further
than to say that if you divided the map
of england into four
quarters he would have been found in the
south southwestern of them
he was a man of academic pursuits and
his term was just over
he was on his way to meet a new friend
older than himself
the two of them had met first on an
official inquiry in town
had found that they had many tastes and
habits in common
liked each other and the result was an
invitation from squire richards to mr
fanshaw
which was now taking effect the journey
ended about five o'clock
fanshaw was told by a cheerful country
porter that the car from the hall had
been up to the station
and left a message that something had to
be fetched from half a mile farther on
and would the gentleman please to wait a
few minutes till it came back
but i see continued the porter as you've
got your bicycle
and very like you'd find it pleasanter
to ride up to the hall yourself
straight up the road here and then first
turn to the left
it ain't above two miles and i'll see as
your things is put in the car for you
you'll excuse me mentioning it only i
thought it was a nice evening for a ride
yes sir very seasonable weather for the
haymakers
let me see i have your bike ticket thank
you sir much obliged
you can't miss your road the two miles
to the hall
were just what was needed after the day
in the train to dispel somnolence and
impart a wish for tea
the hall when cited also promised just
what was needed
in the way of a quiet resting place
after days of sitting on committees and
college meetings
it was neither excitingly old nor
depressingly new
plastered walls sash windows old trees
smooth lawns
were the features which fanshawe noticed
as he came up the drive
squire richards a burly man of 60 odd
was awaiting him in the porch with
evident pleasure
t first he said or would you like a
longer drink
no alright tea is ready in the garden
come along they'll put your machine away
i always have tea
under the lime tree by the stream on a
day like this
nor could you ask for a better place
mid-summer afternoon
shade and scent of a vast lime tree cool
swirling water within five yards
it was long before either of them
suggested a move
but about six mr richard sat up knocked
out his pipe and said
look here it's cool enough now to think
of a stroll if you're inclined
alright then what i suggest is that we
walk up the park and get onto the
hillside
where we can look over the country we'll
have a map and i'll show you where
things are
and you can go off on your machine or we
can take the car
according as you want exercise or not if
you're ready we can start now
and be back well before eight taking it
very easy
i'm ready i should like my stick though
and have you got any field glasses
i lent mine to a man a week ago and he's
gone off lord knows where and taken them
with him
mr richards pondered yes he said
i have but they're not things i use
myself and i don't know whether the ones
i have will suit you
they're old-fashioned and about twice as
heavy as they make them now
you're welcome to have them but i won't
carry them
by the way what do you want to drink
after dinner
protestations that anything would do
were overruled
and a satisfactory settlement was
reached on the way to the front hall
where mr fanshawe found his stick and mr
richards
after thoughtful pinching of his lower
lip resorted to a drawer in the hall
table
extracted a key crossed to a cupboard in
the paneling
opened it took a box from the shelf and
put it on the table
the glasses are in there he said and
there's some dodge of opening it
but i've forgotten what it is you try
mr fanshaw accordingly tried there was
no keyhole
and the box was solid heavy and smooth
it seemed obvious that some part of it
would have to be pressed before anything
could happen
the corners said he to himself are the
likely places
and infernally sharp corners they are
too he added as he put his thumb in his
mouth after exerting force on a lower
corner
what's the matter said the squire why
your disgusting borgia box has scratched
me
drat it said fanshawe the squire
chuckled unfeelingly
well you've got it open anyway he said
so i have
well i don't begrudge a drop of blood in
a good cause
and here are the glasses they are pretty
heavy
as you said but i think i'm equal to
carrying them
ready said the squire come on then we go
out by the garden
so they did and passed out into the park
which sloped decidedly upwards to the
hill
which as fanshawe had seen from the
train dominated the country
it was a spur of a larger range that lay
behind
on the way the squire who was great on
earthworks
pointed out various spots where he
detected or imagined
traces of war ditches and the like and
here
he said stopping on a more or less level
plot with a ring of large trees
is baxter's roman villa baxter
said mr fanshaw i forgot you don't know
about him
he was the old chap i got those glasses
from i believe he made them he was an
old watchmaker down in the village
a great antiquary my father gave him
leave to grub about where he liked
and when he made a find he used to lend
him a man or two to help him with the
digging
he got a surprising lot of things
together and when he died
i dare say it's 10 or 15 years ago i
bought the whole lot
and gave them to the town museum we'll
run in one of these days and look over
them
the glasses came to me with the rest but
of course i kept them
if you look at them you'll see their
more or less amateur work
the body of them naturally the lenses
weren't his making
yes i see they are just the sort of
thing that a clever workman in a
different line of business might turn
out
but i don't see why he made them so
heavy and did baxter actually find a
roman villa here
yes there's a pavement turfed over where
we're standing
it was too rough and plain to be worth
taking up but of course there are
drawings of it
and the small things in pottery that
turned up were quite good of their kind
an ingenious chap old baxter he seemed
to have a quite out of the way
instinct for these things he was
invaluable to our archaeologists
he used to shut up his shop for days at
a time and wander off over the district
marking down places where he centered
anything on the ordinance map
and he kept a book with fuller notes of
the places
since his death a good many of them have
been sampled and there's always been
something to justify him
what a good man said mr fanshaw
good said the squire pulling up bruskly
i meant useful to have about the place
said mr fanshaw
but was he a villain i don't know about
that either
said the squire but all i can say is if
he was good he wasn't lucky
and he wasn't liked i didn't like him he
added after a moment
oh said fanshawe interrogatively
no i didn't but that's enough about
baxter
besides this is the stiffest bit and i
don't want to talk and walk as well
indeed it was hot climbing a slippery
grass slope that evening
i told you i should take you the short
way panted the squire
and i wish i hadn't however a bath won't
do us any harm when we get back
here we are and there's the seat a small
clump of old scotch furs crowned the top
of the hill
and at the edge of it commanding the
cream of the view was a wide and solid
seat
on which the two disposed themselves and
wiped their brows and regained breath
now then said the squire as soon as he
was in a condition to talk connectedly
this is where your glasses come in but
you'd better take a general look round
first
my word i've never seen the view look
better
writing as i am now with a winter wind
flapping against dark windows
and a rushing tumbling sea within a
hundred yards
i find it hard to sum it up the feelings
and words which will put my reader in
possession of the june evening
and the lovely english landscape of
which the squire was speaking
across a broad level plain they looked
upon ranges of great hills
whose uplands some green some furred
with woods
caught the light of a sun western but
not yet low
and all the plane was fertile though the
river which traversed it was nowhere
seen
there were copses green wheat hedges and
pasture land
the little compact white moving cloud
marked the evening train
then the eye picked out red farms and
gray houses
and nearer homes scattered cottages and
then the hall
nestled under the hill the smoke of
chimneys was very blue and straight
there was a smell of hay in the air
there were wild roses on bushes hard by
it was the acme of summer after some
minutes of silent contemplation
the squire began to point out the
leading features the hills and valleys
and told where the towns and villages
lay
now he said with the glasses you'll be
able to pick out fullneck or abbey
take a line across that big green field
then over the wood beyond it
then over the farm on the knoll yes yes
said fanshawe i've got it what a fine
tower
you must have got the wrong direction
said the squire there's not much of a
tower about there that i remember
unless it's old-born church that you've
got hold of and if you call that a fine
tower you're easily pleased
well i do call it a fine tower said
fanshawe the glasses still at his eyes
whether it's oldborn or any other and it
must belong to a largest church
it looks to me like a central tower four
big pinnacles at the corners
and four smaller ones between i must
certainly go over there
how far is it old born's about nine
miles or less
said the squire it's a long time since
i've been there
but i don't remember thinking much of it
now i'll show you another thing
fanshawe had lowered the glasses and was
still gazing in the old born direction
no he said i can't make out anything
with the naked eye
what was it you were going to show me a
good deal more to the left
it ought to be difficult to find do you
see a rather sudden knob of a hill
with a thick wood on top of it it's in a
dead line with that single tree on the
top of the big ridge
i do said fanshawe and i believe i could
tell you without much difficulty what
it's called
could you now said the squire say on
why gallows hill was the answer
how did you guess that well if you don't
want it guessed you shouldn't put up a
dummy jibbet
and a man hanging on it what's that said
the squire abruptly
there's nothing on that hill but wood on
the contrary
said fanshawe there's a large expanse of
grass on the top
and your dummy jibbed in the middle and
i thought there was something on it when
i looked first
but i see there's nothing or is there i
can't be sure
nonsense nonsense fanshawe there's no
such thing as a dummy jibbet or any
other sort on that hill
and it's thick wood a fairly young
plantation
i was in it myself not a year ago hand
me the glasses
though i don't suppose i can see
anything after a pause
no i thought not they won't show a thing
[Music]
meanwhile fanshawe was scanning the hill
it might be only two or three miles away
well it's very odd he said it does look
exactly
like a wood without the glass he took it
again
that is one of the oddest effects the
gibbet is perfectly plain
and the grass field and there even
seemed to be people on it and carts
or a cart with men in it and yet when i
take the glass away
there's nothing it must be something in
the way this afternoon light falls
i shall come up earlier in the day when
the sun's full on it
did you say you saw people in a cart on
that hill
said the squire incredulously what
should they be doing there at this time
of day
even if the trees have been felled do
talk sense
look again well i certainly thought i
saw them
yes i should say there were a few just
clearing off
and now by jove it does look like
something hanging on the jibbet
but these glasses are so beastly heavy i
can't hold them steady for long
anyhow you can take it from me there's
no wood and if you'll show me the road
on the map
i'll go there tomorrow the squire
remained brooding for some little time
at last he rose and said well i suppose
that will be the best way to settle it
and now we'd better be getting back bath
and dinner is my idea
and on the way back he was not very
communicative
they returned through the garden and
went into the front hall to leave sticks
etc
in their due place and here they found
the aged butler patton
evidently in a state of some anxiety
beg pardon master henry he began at once
but someone's been up to mischief here
i'm much afraid
he pointed to the open box which had
contained the glasses
nothing worse than that patton said the
squire may and i take out my own glasses
and lend them to a friend
bought them with my own money you
recollect an old baxter's sale eh
patent bowed unconvinced oh very well
master henry as long as you know who it
was
only i thought proper to name it for i
didn't think that box had been off its
shelf
since you first put it there and if
you'll excuse me after what happened
the voice was lowered and the rest was
not audible to fanshawe
the squire replied with a few words and
a gruff laugh
and called on fanshawe to come and be
shown his room
and i do not think that anything else
happened that night which bears on my
story
except perhaps the sensation which
invaded fanshawe in the small hours
that something had been let out which
ought not to have been let out
it came into his dreams he was walking
in a garden which he seemed half to know
and stopped in front of a rockery made
of old wrought stones
pieces of window tracery from a church
and even bits of figures
one of these moved his curiosity it
seemed to be a sculptured capital with
scenes carved on it
he felt he must pull it out and worked
away and with an ease that surprised him
moved the stones that obscured it aside
and pulled out the block
as he did so a tin label fell down by
his feet with a little clatter
he picked it up and read on it on no
account move this stone
you're sincerely jay patton
as often happens in dreams he felt that
this injunction was of extreme
importance
and with an anxiety that amounted to
anguish he looked to see if the stone
had really been shifted
indeed it had in fact he could not see
it anywhere
the removal had disclosed the mouth of a
burrow and he bent down to look into it
something stirred in the blackness and
then
to his intense horror a hand emerged
a clean right hand in a neat cuff and
coat sleeve
just in the attitude of a hand that
means to shake yours
he wondered whether it would not be rude
to let it alone
but as he looked at it it began to grow
hairy and dirty and thin
and also to change its pose and stretch
out as if to take hold of his leg
at that he dropped all thought of
politeness decided to run
screamed and woke himself up
this was the dream he remembered but it
seemed to him
as again it often does that there had
been others of the same
import before but not so insistent
he lay awake for some little time fixing
the details of the last dream in his
mind
and wondering in particular what the
figures had been which he had seen or
half seen
on the carved capital something quite
incongruous he felt sure
but that was the most he could recall
whether because of the dream
or because it was the first day of his
holiday he did not get up very early
nor did he at once plunge into the
exploration of the country
he spent a morning half lazy half
instructive
in looking over the volumes of the
county archaeological society's
transactions
in which were many contributions from mr
baxter on
finds of flint implements roman sites
ruins of monastic establishments
in fact most departments of archaeology
they were written in an odd pompous only
half-educated style
if the man had had more early schooling
thought fanshaw
he would have been a very distinguished
antiquary or he might have been
he thus qualified his opinion a little
later but for a certain love of
opposition and controversy and yes a
patronizing tone
as of one possessing superior knowledge
which left an unpleasant taste
he might have been a very respectable
artist there was an imaginary
restoration and elevation of a priory
church which was very well conceived
a fine pinnacled central tower was a
conspicuous feature of this
it reminded fanshawe that which he had
seen from the hill
and which the squire had told him must
be oldborn
but it was not oldbourne it was
fullnecker priory
oh well he said to himself i suppose
oldborn church may have been built by
fullneck or monks and baxter has copied
old born tower
anything about it in the ah i see it was
published after his death
found among his papers after lunch the
squire asked fanshawe what he meant to
do
well said fanshawe i think i shall go
out on my bike about four
as far as old born and back by gallows
hill
that ought to be a round of about 15
miles often it
about that said the squire and you'll
pass lambsfield and wandstone
both of which are worth looking at
there's a little glass at lambsfield
and the stone at wandstone good
said fanshawe i'll get tea somewhere and
may i take the glasses
i'll strap them on my bike on the
carrier of course if you like
said the squire i really ought to have
some better ones
if i go into the town today i'll see if
i can pick up some
[Music]
why should you trouble to do that if you
can't use them yourself
said fanshawe oh i don't know
one ought to have a decent pair and well
old patton doesn't think those are fit
to use
is he a judge he's got some tail
i don't know something about old baxter
i promise to let him tell me about it
it seems very much on his mind since
last night
why that did he have a nightmare like me
he had something he was looking an old
man this morning
and he said he hadn't closed an eye well
let him save up his tail till i come
back very well
i will if i can look here are you going
to be late
if you get a puncture eight miles off
and have to walk home what then
i don't trust these bicycles i shall
tell them to give us cold things to eat
i shan't mind that
whether i'm late or early but i've got
things to mend punctures with
and now i'm off
it was just as well that the squire had
made that arrangement about a cold
supper
fanshawe thought and not for the first
time as he wheeled his bicycle up the
drive
about nine o'clock so also the squire
thought and said
several times as he met him in the hall
rather pleased at the confirmation of
his want of faith in bicycles
than sympathetic with his hot weary
thirsty and indeed haggard friend
in fact the kindest thing he found to
say was you'll want a long drink tonight
cider cup do alright hear that patton
cider cup iced lots of it then to
fanshawe
don't be all night over your bath by
half past
nine they were at dinner and fanshawe
was reporting progress
if progress it might be called i got to
lambsfield very smoothly
and saw the glass it is very interesting
stuff
but there's a lot of lettering i
couldn't read
not with glasses said the squire those
glasses of yours are no manner of use
inside a church
or inside anywhere i suppose for that
matter but the only places i took them
into are churches
well go on said the squire however i
took some sort of a photograph of the
window and i dare say an enlargement
would show what i want
then one stone i should think that stone
was a very out of the way thing
only i don't know about that class of
antiquities has anybody opened the mound
it stands on
baxter wanted to but the farmer wouldn't
let him
oh well i should think it would be worth
doing
anyhow the next thing was fullnecker and
oldborn
you know it's very odd about that tower
i saw from the hill
oldborn church is nothing like it and of
course there's nothing over 30 feet high
at full maker though you can see it had
a central tower
i didn't tell you did i that baxter's
fancy drawing of fullnecker
shows a tower exactly like the one i saw
so you thought i dare say put in the
squire
no it wasn't a case of thinking the
picture actually reminded me of what i'd
seen
and i made sure it was oldborn well
before i looked at the title
well baxter had a very fair idea of
architecture
i dare say what's left made it easy for
him to draw the right sort of tower
that may be it of course but i'm
doubtful if even a professional could
have got it so exactly right
there's absolutely nothing left at full
maker but the bases of the piers which
supported it
however that isn't the oddest thing
what about gallows hill said the squire
here patton listen to this
i told you what mr fanshawe said he saw
from the hill
yes master henry you did and i can't say
i was so much surprised considering
alright alright you keep that till
afterwards we want to hear what mr
fanshaw saw today
go on fanshawe you turned to come back
by akford and thorfield i suppose
yes and i looked into both the churches
then i got to the turning which goes to
the top of gallows hill
i saw that if i wheeled my machine over
the field at the top of the hill
i could join the home road on this side
it was about half past six when i got to
the top of the hill
and there was a gate on my right where
it ought to be leading into the belt of
plantation
you hear that patton a belt he says
so i thought it was a belt but it wasn't
you were quite right and i was
hopelessly wrong i cannot understand it
the whole top is planted quite thick
well
i went on into this wood wheeling and
dragging my bike
expecting every minute to come to a
clearing and then my
misfortunes began thorns i suppose
first i realized that the front tire was
slack then the back
i couldn't stop to do more than try to
find the punctures and mark them
but even that was hopeless so i plowed
on
and the farther i went the less i liked
the place
not much poaching in that cover apaton
said the squire
no indeed master henry there's very few
cares to go
no i know never mind that now go on
fanshawe
i don't blame anybody for not caring to
go there i know i had all the fancies
one least likes
steps crackling over twigs behind me
indistinct people stepping behind trees
in front of me
yes and even a hand laid on my shoulder
i pulled up very sharp at that and
looked round
but there really was no branch or bush
that could have done it
then when i was just about at the middle
of the plot i was convinced that there
was someone looking down on me from
above
and not with any pleasant intent i
stopped again
or at least slackened my pace to look up
and as i did
down i came and barked my shins
abominably on
what do you think a block of stone with
a big square hole in the top of it
and within a few paces there were two
others just like it
the three were set in a triangle now do
you make out what they were put there
for
i think i can said the squire who was
now very grave and absorbed in the story
sit down patton it was time
for the old man was supporting himself
by one hand and leaning heavily on it
he dropped into a chair and said in a
very tremulous voice
you didn't go between them stones did
you sir
i did not said fanshaw emphatically
i dare say i was an ass but as soon as
it dawned on me where i was
i just shouldered my machine and did my
best to run
it seemed to me as if i was in an unholy
evil sort of graveyard
and i was most profoundly thankful that
it was one of the longest days and still
sunlight
well i had a horrid run even if it was
only a few hundred yards
everything caught on everything handles
and spokes and carrier and petals
caught in them viciously or i fancied so
i fell over at least five times
at last i saw the hedge and i couldn't
trouble to hunt for the gate
there is no gate on my side the squire
interpolated
just as well i didn't waste time then i
dropped the machine over somehow and
went into the road pretty near head
first
some branch or something got my ankle at
the last moment
anyhow there i was out of the wood and
seldom more thankful or more generally
sore
then came the job of mending my
punctures
i had a good outfit and i'm not at all
bad at the business
but this was an absolutely hopeless case
it was seven when i got out of the wood
and i spent 50 minutes over one
tire as fast as i found a hole and put
on a patch and blew it up
it went flat again so i made up my mind
to walk
that hill isn't three miles away is it
not more across country but nearer six
by road
i thought it must be i thought i
couldn't have taken well over the hour
over less than five miles even leading a
bike
well there's my story where's yours and
patents
mine i've no story said the squire but
you weren't very far out when you
thought you were in a graveyard
there must be a good few of them up
there patton don't you think
they left him there when they fell to
bits i fancy
patton nodded too much interested to
speak
now then patton said the squire you've
heard what sort of a time mr fanshaw's
been having
what do you make of it anything to do
with mr baxter
fill yourself a glass of port and tell
us
ah that done me good master henry said
patton after absorbing what was before
him
if you really wish to know what was in
my thoughts my answer would be clear in
the affirmative
yes he went on warming to his work i
should say as mr fanshawe's experience
of today was very largely due to the
person you named
and i think master henry as i have some
title to speak
in view of me having been many years on
speaking terms with him
and swore in to be jury on the coroner's
inquest near this time
10 years ago you being then if you carry
your mind back master henry
traveling abroad and no one here to
represent the family
inquest said fanshawe an inquest on mr
baxter was there
yes sir on on that very person
the facts has led up to that occurrence
was these
the deceased was as you may have
gathered a very peculiar individual in
his habits
in my idea at least but all must speak
as they find
he lived very much to himself without
neither chick nor child as the saying is
and how he passed away his time was what
very few could offer a guess at
he lived unknown and few could know when
baxter ceased to be
said the squire to his pipe i beg pardon
master henry i was just coming to that
but when i say how he passed away his
time to be sure we know how intent he
was in rummaging and ransacking
out all the history of the neighborhood
and the number of things he'd managed to
collect together
well it was spoke of for miles round as
baxter's museum
and many a time when he might be in the
mood and i might have an hour to spare
have he showed me his pieces of pots and
whatnot going back by his account to the
times of the ancient romans
however you know more about that than
what i do master henry
only what i was going to say was this as
no woody might and
interesting as he might be in his talk
there was something about the man
well for one thing no one ever
remembered to see him in church nor yet
chapel at service time
and that made talk our rector he never
come in the house but once
never asked me what the man said that
was all anybody could ever get out of
him
then how did he spend his nights
particularly about this season of the
year
time and again the laboring men had meet
him coming back as they went out to
their work
and he'd pass him by without a word
looking they says like someone straight
out of the asylum
they see the whites of his eyes all
round he'd have a fish basket with him
that they noticed and he always come the
same road
and the talk got to be that he'd made
himself some business and that not the
best kind
well not so far from where you was at
seven o'clock this evening sir
well now after such a night as that mr
baxter he'd shut up the shop
and the old lady that did for him had
orders not to come in
and knowing what she did about his
language she took care to obey those
orders
but one day it so happened about three
o'clock in the afternoon
the house being shut up as i said there
come a most fearful to do inside
and smoke out of the windows and baxter
crying out
seemingly in agony so the man has lived
next door
he run run to the back premises and
burst the door in and several others
came too
well he told me he never in all his life
smelt such a fearful
well odor as what there was in that
kitchen place
it seemed as if baxter had been boiling
something in a pot
and overset it on his leg there he lay
on the floor
trying to keep back the cries but it was
more than he could manage
and when he seen the people come in oh
he was in a nice condition
if his tongue weren't blistered worse
than his leg it weren't his fault
well they picked him up and got him into
a chair and run for the medical man
and one of them was going to pick up the
pot and baxter
he screams out to let it alone so he did
but he couldn't see as there was
anything in the pot but a few old brown
bones then they says dr lawrence will be
here in a minute mr baxter
he'll soon put you to rights and then he
was off again
he must be got up to his room he
couldn't have the doctor come in there
and see all that mess
they must throw a cloth over it anything
the tablecloth out of the parlor
well so they did but that must have been
poisonous stuff in that pot
for it was pretty near on two months
before baxter was about again
beg pardon master henry were you going
to say something
yes i was said the squire i wonder you
haven't told me all this before
however i was going to say i remember
old lawrence telling me he'd attended
baxter
he was a queer card he said lawrence was
up in the bedroom one day
and picked up a little mask covered with
black velvet
and put it on in fun and went to look at
himself in the glass
he hadn't time for a proper look for old
baxter shouted out to him from the bed
put it down you fool do you want to look
through a dead man's eyes
and it startled him so that he did put
it down and then he asked baxter what he
meant
and baxter insisted on him handing it
over and said the man he bought it from
was dead or some such nonsense
but lawrence felt it as he handed it
over and he declared he was sure it was
made out of the front of a skull
he bought a distilling apparatus at
baxter's sail he told me
but he could never use it it seemed to
taint everything
however much he cleaned it but go on
patton
yes master henry i'm nearly done now and
time too
for i don't know what they'll think
about me in the servants hall
well this business of the scalding was
some few years before mr baxter was took
and he got about again and went on just
as he'd used
and one of the last jobs he done was
finishing up them actual glasses what
you took out last night
you see he'd made the body of them some
long time and got the pieces of glass
for them
but there was something wanted to finish
them whatever it was i don't know
but i picked up the frame one day and i
says mr baxter
why don't you make a job of this and he
says
ah when i've done that you'll hear news
you will there's going to be no such
pair of glasses as mine when they're
filled and sealed
and there he stopped and i says why mr
baxter you talk as if there were wine
bottles
filled and sealed why where's the
necessity for that
did i say filled and sealed he says oh
well
i was suiting my conversation to my
company
well then come round this time of year
and one fine evening i was passing his
shop on my way
home and he was standing on the step
very pleased with himself
and he says all right and tight now my
best bit of work's finished
and i'll be out with them tomorrow what
finish them glasses
i says might i have a look at them
no no he says i put him to bed for
tonight
and when i do show them to you you'll
have to pay for peeping so i tell you
and that gentleman were the last words i
heard that man say
that was the 17th of june and just a
week after
there was a funny thing happened and it
was due to that as we brought in
unsound mind at the inquest for barring
that
knowing his new baxter in business could
anyways have laid that against him
but george williams has lived in the
next house and do now
he was woke up that same night with a
stumbling and tumbling about in mr
baxter's premises
and he got out of bed and went to the
front window on the street to see if
there was any rough customers about
and it being a very light night he could
make sure as there was not
then he stood and listened and he heard
mr baxter coming down his front stair
one step after another very slow and he
got the ideas it was like someone being
pushed or pulled down
and holding on to everything he could
next thing he heard the street door came
open
and out came mr baxter into the street
in his day clothes
hat and all with his arms straight down
by his sides
and talking to himself and shaking his
head from one side to the other
and walking in that peculiar way that he
appeared to be going as it were against
his own will
george williams put up the window and
heard him say
oh mercy gentlemen and then he shut up
sudden as if he said
someone clapped his hand over his mouth
and mr baxter threw his head back
and his hat fell off and williams saw
his face
looking something pitiful so as he
couldn't keep from calling out to him
why mr baxter ain't you well and he was
going to offer to fetch dr lawrence for
him
only he heard the answer tis best you
mind your own business
put in your head but whether it was mr
baxter said it
so horselike and faint he never could be
sure
still there was no one but him in the
street and yet williams was that upset
by the way he spoke that he shrank back
from the window
and went and sat on the bed and he heard
mr baxter's step go on and up the road
and after a minute or more he couldn't
help but look out once more
and he saw him going along the same
curious way as before
and one thing he recollected was that mr
baxter never stopped to pick up his hat
when it fell off
and yet there it was on his head well
master henry
that was the last anybody saw of mr
baxter least ways for a week or more
there was a lot of people said he was
called off on business
or made off because he'd got into some
scrape but he was well known for miles
round
and none of the railway people nor the
public house people hadn't seen him
and then pons was looked into and
nothing found
and at last one evening fakes the keeper
came down from over the hill to the
village
and he says he's seen the gallows hill
planting black with birds
and that were a funny thing because he
never seen no sign of a creature there
in his time
so they looked at each other a bit and
first one says
i'm game to go up and another says so am
i if you are
and half a dozen of them set out in the
evening time and took dr lawrence with
them
and you know master henry there he was
between them three stones
with his neck broke useless to imagine
the talk which this story set going
it is not remembered but before patton
left them he said to fanshawe
excuse me sir but did i understand as
you took out them glasses with you today
i thought you did and might i ask did
you make use of them at all
yes only to look at something in a
church
oh indeed you took him into the church
did you sir
yes i did it was lambsfield church by
the way i left them strapped onto my
bicycle i'm afraid
in the stable yard no matter for that
sir i can bring them in first thing
tomorrow
and perhaps you'll be so good as to look
at him then
accordingly before breakfast after a
tranquil and well-earned sleep
fanshawe took the glasses into the
garden and directed them to a distant
hill
he lowered them instantly and looked at
top and bottom
worked the screws tried them again and
yet again
shrugged his shoulders and replaced them
on the hall table
patton he said they're absolutely
useless
i can't see a thing it's as if someone
stuck a black wafer over the lens
spoilt my glasses have you said the
squire
thank you the only ones i've got you try
them yourself
said fanshawe i've done nothing to them
so after breakfast the squire took them
out to the terrace and stood
on the steps after a few ineffectual
attempts
lord how heavy they are he said
impatiently and in the same
instant dropped them onto the stones and
the lens splintered and the barrel
cracked
a little pool of liquid formed on the
stone's slab
it was inky black and the odor that rose
from it is not to be described
filled and sealed a said the squire if i
could bring myself to touch it
i dare say we should find the seal so
that's what came of his boiling and
distilling is it
old ghoul what in the world do you mean
don't you see my good man remember what
he said to the doctor about looking
through dead men's eyes
well this was another way of it but they
didn't like having their bones boiled i
take it
and the end of it was they carried him
off whether he would not
well i'll get a spade and we'll bury
this thing decently
as they smooth the turf over it the
squire handing the spade to patton
who had been a reverential spectator
remarked to fanshawe
it's almost a pity you took that thing
into the church
you might have seen more than you did
baxter had them for a week i
make out but i don't see that he did
much in the time
i'm not sure said fanshawe there is that
picture
of fullnecker priory church
you